and it's confirmed that it's carried out
a nuclear test it's conducted in the
north of the country South Korean
officials say that the force of the
blast set off an artificial earthquake
of a magnitude of 5.3 for more our
politics editor for the Korea's Andy
sharp joins us from Tokyo Andy what is
North Korea claiming okay well in a
statement on its state-run news channel
the North Koreans just announced - about
20-30 minutes ago that it managed to
detonate a nuclear warhead in the test
and says it now has the ability to mount
these warheads onto rockets in other
words you know they can produce
miniaturized nuclear arms which if true
means they can be fitted onto rockets
and fired further putting potentially
you know a wider range of countries at
risk of an attack to what extent and I
say this with a certain amount of
brevity which is to what extent can we
believe them it's still a little bit too
early in terms of the credibility of
these claims is it - 100% believe them
yeah absolutely I mean their last test
the fourth test they conducted in
January the North Koreans claimed to
have produced a hydrogen bomb but every
expert we spoke to government officials
from you know all the key players Japan
the u.s. South Korea countries around
the world all said no this was not
hydrogen test North Korea on North
Korea's claims don't stand up for now
it's it's still a little bit early to
say whether they have produced this
miniaturized weapon but we should
definitely have a heavy dose of
skepticism around their claims Andy one
of the implications for the wider region
I mean we're seeing a sell-off in Korean
stocks and in the warned we're seeing
Japanese stock swing between gains and
losses what what are the implications
well the implication is basically in how
how do we stop North Korea you know
continuing to
fired missiles if it fired three
missiles last week nuclear tests just
conducted its fifth test how do we stop
this the onus is clearly on on China
China's its own official it's the only
official ally of Pyongyang's in the
region
Japan's strengthening sanctions the USA
will probably knock off tougher measures
so it all depends on whether China can
use you know sanctions or other
diplomatic means of turning the screw on
North Korea otherwise we don't see any
particular way way or any method of
slowing down
what seems to be an accelerated program
of missile and nuclear tests
it certainly is heightening the tensions
and e-sharp there in Tokyo thank you so
much just to recap Obama has been on the
tape President Obama he's just left the
region he says that he will consult with
allies over the coming days in regards
to North Korea's actions he reiterated
the u.s. commitment to the Asian allies
and Obama has talked to South Korea's
Park Japan's
our BAE in separate cause and he's been
fully briefed on the matter joining us
now is Simon Derek chief currency
strategist at BNY Mellon Simon let's
just start with this story of course
we're seeing you know a sell-off in the
one though this after it was what at its
highest since April 2015 month I a 15
month high yesterday you know is this an
overreaction given that we often get
these sort of tests and use of these
tests coming out no don't think it's an
overreaction I mean I think the actual
reaction in the career market socially
pretty mild we know we both our malice
is right that we don't have the final
details of those tests yet nevertheless
it's it's the next stage along a very
long winding story there's been going on
for what five 10 years now the
interesting thing for me is relatively
speaking the lack of reaction we're
getting in markets overall now you could
say that people know just used to what's
happening in North Korea how often do we
get one of these stories but
nevertheless it is still a major issue I
think that what we're actually looking
at here though is a market that has
become you
mewn to geopolitics overall look over
the course last 12 months look at the
black or actions what was happening on
the turkish-syrian border look at the
relative lack of reaction to events in
Paris
well the Turkish coup this is a market
that's becoming so heavily focused on
yields seeking than almost anything else
gets blotted out and I think the
relative lucky reaction here just speaks
to that